entrepreneur and author Jesse it sirs
known for taking on extreme challenges
he trained with he trained with the Navy
SEAL remember that ran a 100 mile
marathon and climbed Mount Washington
more than six thousand feet high and a
snowstorm of cross of course as one does
it's there's an owner of the Atlanta
Hawks he co-founded Marquis Jet the
world's largest private jet card company
in his new book it's a writes about
slowing down for a different kind of
personal challenge it's called living
with the monks what turning off my phone
taught me about happiness gratitude and
focus Jesse it's or joins us once again
at the table good morning welcome back
thank you now you admit in the book
you're a ready fire aim person which
means you don't always think things
totally through example you go to the
monk the monastery you've shaved your
head and you get there and you think
you're the only ball guy there you can
do any research before you went there
either they don't shave their hair
anymore Jesse right I just wanted to
experience I didn't want to have a
preconceived idea of what this
experience was gonna be I just wanted to
go and enjoy it so I thought monks
equals shaved head and so you wanted to
learn the how-to what do you mean by
that well I just wanted to learn how to
have better routines and better habits
and a better mindset I feel like I've
invested so much in the physical side of
my life running marathons I've brought a
steal into my house I have a trainer
yeah but I've invested very little on
the inner work and in a world of
distractions I felt like they had the
whole picture I really had to spend a
little time alone and work on being
present and what did turning off your
phone teach you about happiness and
gratitude and focus well I realize I
don't spend a lot of time thinking you
know I ask Siri questions I go to Alexa
I google but I don't spend a lot of time
alone actually thinking it's like a lost
art form yeah and I realized that just
being alone and getting away from my
phone everything the important things
kind of come to the surface and you know
I've four kids under 8 and I just wanted
to be able to be the best father the
best husband and thought that you know
who are the Masters and then everything
pointed to monk's mm-hmm
we should note that by the way the seal
you had to live to you with is a Navy
SEAL people might say that is good
art Burke's next let me ask you this
about monks the reason they have these
routines the reason they have these
daily lives devoted in the way they do
is because they are it is all for the
glory of God they do what they do during
the day for the purpose of stripping
everything way so they can have a
relationship with God but you sound like
you this is where was God in the picture
that you you know it wasn't a big thing
for me
I went there just to be alone I went
there to experience you can learn a lot
when you when you're around people that
are completely different than yourself
and they were the exact opposite of how
I live my life my life is ready fire aim
and it is one of adventure so I went
there really just to see like well how
what's their lifestyle and how are they
how are their feet always on the ground
how are they always where their feet are
and take some of those lessons and apply
them to my busy modern day life are
usually reason their feets always on the
ground because God's at the center of
their life yeah but also I think that
that they're always super present I
remember one of the first days there I
realized I was getting a lot of these
like mr. Miyagi Karate Kid lessons
through watching them and they've
stacked up all these dishes I was in
charge of dishes I was like the rookie
on the team
and they had all these dishes stacked up
like hundreds from a retreat and I
started cleaning the dishes and I turned
to one of them one of the monks and said
I'm never gonna finish all these dishes
and he said you don't have all these
dishes you only have the one that's in
your hand yeah and I realized that my
mind even when I'm at a soccer game I'm
on my to-do list yeah I'm at dinner I'm
like well I gotta go home and cross
things off my to-do list but they didn't
they didn't have a to-do list they do
lists right and that's what they were
doing they do things one thing at a time
until the job is done but I'm curious
about what you learned because brother
Chris said do you Jesse are you happy
and you had to think about that for a
second because Sara Blakely your wife we
all know spanks we a lot of us were
spanks at the table she says that you
were very challenged when it comes to
expressing your feelings did it change
how you express yourself now you move
around in your world today well my wife
always says when we communicate in a
relationship you have to play tennis and
hit the ball back yeah I kind of not a
good volley er yeah but it did I mean
you can't really be truly intimate and I
don't mean intimate yes actually I mean
emotionally unless you're fully present
and I struggle with that I think a lot
of people struggle with
and this is you know spending time alone
by myself thinking really helped me in
that I'm very aware when I'm with my
wife did the ball back yes well now you
both yeah bye Dave five you were
thinking do I have a book here you
weren't so sure but as time went on use
it you there's something here yeah well
I was getting all these different
lessons and I summarized ten in the book
you know ten really specific lessons
that helped me have those winning habits
winning routines and a winning mindset
no investors there's no lid on happiness
I love that there yeah no lid on
happiness we can always do better be
better JT go always good to see you
jesse has a fun life living with the
monks is on sale now wherever you like
to buy your books